so you mentioned kind of
people who what the bitcoin community
might call
scammers
i have a lot of passions in my life that
i focus a lot of my attention to
uh you know bitcoin doesn't happen to be
yet one of them bitcoin in
cryptocurrency
you know i said yeah i
i'm always looking um for things to
really fall in love with
so how is a person like me supposed to
figure out i also happen to have a
platform a little bit
and how am i supposed to figure out
who is a interesting uh what is an
interesting set of ideas
and what are not because people are
financially tied into a lot of the
cryptocurrencies that we're talking
about certainly with bitcoin
you know their livelihood their
well-being is tied up to it so it
becomes much more emotional much more
personal
it's no longer purely an exploration of
ideas
it's really almost like a threat on your
property like
it's a personal threat it makes it very
difficult to explore those ideas so
i understand it but it makes it very
difficult for somebody like me to just
walk in and be curious
so how do i proceed in this difficult
world
in exploring this landscape and
not give a platform to ideas that may
uh that may harm others
i guess first i'd like to commend your
forthrightness about this because i
don't think many people
try to walk that line necessarily people
again kind of the territorial imperative
they'll put whoever on they'll help
expand their reach
oh yeah you know i don't or say whatever
needs to be said to expand their reach
so i think
you're coming from a good place i'll say
that um
there's a great piece written on the
topic of scammers and scamming
uh i think it was by goldstein he wrote
a piece called everyone's a scammer
and it's sort of back to this you know
general human proclivity to try and get
something for nothing
always which again it can be positive
it can be innovative or it can be
negative you can be trying to steal from
people
yeah um
might be i think that's a useful piece
just to kind of
see the crypto world through that lens
and that's how bitcoiners are thinking
all the time they're by nature
adversarial thinkers so they're trying
to minimize the need for trust in any
situation and maximize verification
um as far as sifting through
the ideas i i guess
this is back where the cultural immune
system has some utility
yeah because i there were times when i
thought this
particular crypto asset you know auger
was one i was really into that
it could facilitate prediction markets
and prediction markets make
um you know markets more efficient et
cetera et cetera
but when that investment thesis
basically met
the cultural uh filter or immune system
it forced me to reevaluate my position
forced me to really look into it more
deeply
and through that exploration i realized
that it would need to be built on
bitcoin to work
basically so but it really comes down to
like you doing your homework
but we can't all deeply evaluate every
idea out there right yeah one of the
things i struggle with
with alex jones for example had had
dinner with him
uh that i could tell that would be a
very fun conversation
but like then i also understand that
there's
like consequences to that conversation
that should be uh explored with care and
uh so you should you need to take on the
responsibility of being a chef of the
puffer fish and all those kinds of
things
that said just like you said it's very
difficult to know this ahead of time
and i will probably make mistakes
and that's a shitty thing to have to
live with
that i'm going to make mistakes and some
of them very large
like um yeah i mean i can imagine a
bunch of different ways
but all we can do in this world is once
we make the mistakes
we acknowledge those mistakes yes learn
and learn and also you know i have to
put this on the
on on the rest of us that
you don't take one thing that a person
did
and then burn them at the stake for it
that
uh you realize that we all make mistakes
that a particular mistake does not make
the person
and you know this applies to taking
stuff out of context over
you know hundreds of hours of talking
but it applies to actual
like in context big mistake
okay so what if i murdered somebody at
some point just give me a break no
there are some things that are too far
of course but
in general uh we need to give each other
a chance
yeah but i'm still
i walk with a heavy heart knowing that
i'll probably make a mistake
especially one that i didn't mean to
that's the one that worries me most well
this is human nature
like hamartia to miss the mark
that's the root word of sin we are
sinful by nature we can't help it
there's no way again pain is information
right there's no way to learn
other than trying failing
learning and then you put yourself in
better formation
right in formation to better deal with
it next time so i i
i hope i don't get the sense that you're
actually
afraid of work or of making a messed up
like i think
you're just um maybe disappointed it's a
better word like you know you're gonna
make the mistake yes
that's exactly that's a much much better
word but we have to embrace that
yeah that's the only way anything it's
the only way we can advance
is that we're dealing with an
incomprehensible reality all we can do
is throw spaghetti at the wall and see
what sticks
yeah and in that process we're all you
know inherently gonna
hurt ourselves and hurt others and
that's where love and forgiveness come
into play
right and um
yeah i think the the other thing is that
this culture of reducing people down to
a label
right whether it's racism or whether
you're calling them a scammer or
any number of terms you're you're
discounting their sovereignty to zero
right you're taking a super complex
human
that is vast contains multitudes is
changing over time
and you're trying to put them in a
bucket of a word
and that is just i think a cognitive
fallacy
like that's not only going to hurt the
person that you're you know
winnowing down to a word it's also going
to hurt you and it's going to
in your attempt to decomplexify reality
by assigning this person to a term
you're actually going to create bad
outcomes for yourself
because you're not going to understand
that person i do also think there's the
failure of our
social media technology that
incentivizes that kind of reduce
reduction to a label it's just the
the viral nature of that reduction so
it's not not only do we humans naturally
do that
the our social media platforms
make that easier more fun uh
more effective to do that at scale the
mass hysteria
so i think there's actually uh like
technological ways of
uh adding friction to that yeah i wonder
i mean i agree with you that it's social
media is an amplifier to our natural
uh this natural way of dealing with one
another but i wonder
and my thinking has evolved a lot on
this that there's something below the
way we're treating each other to
right that we could say civilization
sort of advances
in the tools we make and the way we
treat each other we tend to have better
tools
better quality of life and better
morality better
quality of living and ways of dealing
with one another
and i think that when you corrupt the
money
that it really does push us the the
negative direction
pushes us away from uh
again encouraging or amplify magnifying
scarcity artificially causes us to be
more divisive
when things are more divisive we tend to
be less civilized less nuanced
more you know black or white or this or
that or
you're you're this or your label a or
label b
so i really think and this is a harder
one to unravel but
i think if we can fix the money right
which again is the base layer operating
system
for human moral action in the world
that it has downstream effects so we'd
actually maybe start to treat each other
a little better
on social media despite the fact that it
enables this
faster communication that's interesting
so perhaps
fixing like social media as i've been
thinking about
is treating the symptom not the cause
you